Guten Abend Herr Oberarzt, ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen. Ich würde gerne über ihn berichten.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich? Ja bitte. Danke.
Herr Lange ist 66 Jahre alt, 1,76 Meter groß und 71 Kilogramm schwer.
Herr Lange ist ein 66 jähriger Patient, der sich heute bei uns wegen seit gestern Abend bestehender, erstmaliger, plötzlich aufgetretener, persistierender, linksseitiger, hypogastischer Abdominal Schmerzen ohne Schallung vorstellte.
Dem Patienten zufolge seien die Schmerzen nach dem Abendessen aufgetreten und im Laufe der Zeit schlimmer geworden.
Die Schmerzintensität wurde auf einer Schmerzkala am Anfang mit 5 von 10 und momentan mit 7 von 10 bewertet.
Außerdem berichtete er über Pyrexie und Schüterfrost. Der Patient habe das Fieber nicht gemessen.
Der Patient hat die Schmerzen nach dem Abendessen auf einer Koloskopie mit 3 Jahren durchgeführt.
Der Patient hat die Koloskopie mit 3 Jahren durchgeführt.
Die Schmerzen nach dem Abendessen auf einer Koloskopie mit 3 Jahren durchgeführt.
Die folgenden Anamnesen bei der vegetativen Anamnese seien bekannt.
Die Obstration war seit Langem.
Die Schnauze und Atemstillstand bedingte Insomnie und Schmerzen bedingte Inapetens.
Vor Erkrankungen gab der Patient Arterielle Hypertonie seit 10 Jahren, Morbus Bechterew seit 15 Jahren,
Hypolypidemie seit 10 Jahren, Tier vor 8 Jahren und Obststift Schlafapne-Syndrom an.
Der Patient nehme gegen Arterielle Hypertonie eine Tablette.
Diese Tablette sollte geklärt werden.
Er nehme gegen Morbus Bechterew Methotrexat, 12,5 mg Spritzen pro Woche und Vollsäure ein.
Aber man hat es zuerst nicht benutzt.
Der Patient nehme eine Medikamente gegen Arterielle Hypertonie ein.
Der wird statt und die Dosierung sollte geklärt werden.
Die Dosierung sollte geklärt werden.
Zolten.
Der Patient Spritze gegen Morbus Bechterew Methotrexat, 12,5 mg und er nehme Vollsäure ein.
Der Patient nehme Arterielle Arterielle Hypertonie ein.
Der Patient nehme ein Milogramm Arterielle Arterielle Hypertonie ein.
Der Patient nimmt eine Medikamente gegen Arterielle Hypertonie ein.
Der Patient nehme Arterielle Arterielle Hypertonie ein.
Der Patient hat vor 20 Jahren eine Prostatektomie durchgeführt.
Der Patient hat eine Allergie gegen Nickel, die sich exanthem äußert.
Er raucht eine Schachtel Zigaretten seit 50 Jahren.
Das entspricht 50 Packungsjahr.
Der Patient trinkt 1-2 Flaschen Bier täglich.
Er trug einen Konsum oder verneint.
Er trägt regelmäßig keinen Sport.
In der Familienanamnese gab er an, dass der Vater wegen eines Verkehrsunfalls gestorben sei.
Die Mutter ist 70 Jahre alt und ist an Kolonkarsinom gestorben.
Er hat keine Geschwister.
Er ist verheiratet und hat zwei gesunde Kinder.
Er ist Taxifahrer und hat viel Stress bei der Arbeit.
Ich gehe von einem Verdacht auf eine Diathekritik aus.
Der Patient hat typische Symptome.
Der Patient hat Pyrexie, linksseitige Unterbauchschmerzen und eine divertikelle Folgeschichte.
Diese Symptome entsprechen der Vertikulitis.
Als Diagnose kommen Kolonkarsinom, chronische Darmerkrankungen und irritable Colonzentrum in Betracht.
Zunächst würde ich bei den Patienten die Vitaparameter überwachen und eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Zusätzlich ist eine Laboruntersuchung sinnvoll, um eine umfassende Diagnostik zu gewährleisten.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich darauf, ob Hautfarbeveränderungen, Schwellungen oder Lymphknoten vergrößern.
Bei der Palpation achte ich darauf, ob der Patient Druckschmerzen, Abwehrschmerzen und Organomegalie hat.
Dann würde ich die Lekusytensal, CAP, BSG, Leberwerte, Nierenwerte, Gerüntungsparameter,
eine Abdominalsonographie durchführen, um mögliche Pathologie zu beurteilen.
Gegebenenfalls würde ich eine Abdominalsonographie durchführen.
Nach der Behandlung würde ich eine Koloskopie anlassen, um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen.
Darüber hinaus würde ich ein gastroenterologisches und chirurgisches Konsil anfordern, um die Therapie des Patienten zu optimieren.
Darüber hinaus würde ich den Patienten stationär aufnehmen und den Patienten eine venusische Zugang legen.
Dann würde ich die Flüssigkeit, Antibiotika, Antiemetika verbreichen.
Dann würde ich den Patienten die Abteilung des gastroenterologischen Klinik einweisen.
Herr Kollege, wie können wir mit der Abdominalsonographie divertikelisiert werden?
Bei der Abdominalsonographie können wir die Verdichte divertikel beobachten.
Die Verdichtung und die Verdichtung der Differtikel würde ich bei der Untersuchung beobachten.
Herr Kollege, können wir mit der Abdominalsonographie beobachten?
Ja, also, wir können die Verdichte beobachten.
Herr Kollege, Sie werden zuerst die Versuche beobachten.
Ich werde Sie über MRT aufklären.
MRT gehört zu den bildgebenden Verfahren.
Diese Untersuchung beruht mit dem Magnetismus.
Deswegen benötigt diese Untersuchung keine Strahlung und Belastung und ist voll schmerzfrei.
Diese Untersuchung dauert ca. 30 Minuten und Sie sollen in einem MRT-Röhre ruhig liegen.
Wenn Sie Platzangt haben, können wir Ihnen eine leichte Schmerzmittel geben.
Bevor die Untersuchung benötigen Sie keine besondere Vorbereitung.
Sie sollen ein Klopfen Geräusche hören.
Deswegen werden wir Ihnen eine Kopfhörer geben.
Es gibt keine Komplikationen bei dieser Untersuchung.
Aber es gibt einige Komplikationen bei dieser Untersuchung.
Wenn Sie eine Schriftmache haben oder Metallische Körperteile haben,
können Sie nach der Untersuchung Ihr Alltag wie gewohnt fortsetzen.
Es gibt keine Einschränkungen beim Alltag.
Sie sollen Ihre Schmuck und Metallische Körperteile auslegen.
Sie sollen eine Schmerzmache haben.
Dann werden Sie eine Schmerzmache haben.